hey this is presh tallwalker
three spheres are tangent to a plane at
the vertices of a triangle
and are tangent to each other
find the radii of the spheres if the
sides of the triangle are six
eight and 10.
i thank castor for the suggestion
pause the video if you'd like to give
this problem a try
and when you're ready keep watching to
learn how to solve this problem
[Music]
one of the challenging aspects of this
question is to understand the geometry
in three dimensions
use of a computer model will help
understand how the three spheres are
tangent to the plane at the vertices of
a triangle
and are tangent to each other
in order to solve this problem let's
shift our perspective
so the plane is flat
and we're taking a side view of these
two spheres
construct a radius of the large sphere
with its tangency point to the plane and
the vertex of the triangle
let the large sphere have a radius
length equal to a
do the same thing for the smaller sphere
and call its radius length equal to b
construct the following right triangle
where the hypotenuse is the line segment
between the centers of the two spheres
because both spheres are tangent along
the side of the triangle in the plane
and we know their tangent along the
hypotenuse of the 6 8 10 triangle
we know that this leg is equal to 10.
the other leg is then equal to the
difference of the radii lengths so it's
equal to a minus b
the hypotenuse is equal to the sum of
the radii lengths
so this length is equal to a plus b
we thus have the equation 10 squared
plus the quantity a minus b squared is
equal to the quantity a plus b squared
we are going to perform a similar
construction for all the other sides of
the triangle in the plane
so let's shift our perspective between
the following two spheres
we'll construct the following right
triangle
the largest sphere has radius equal to a
and the smaller sphere let's call it c
so we have the legs of this triangle are
a minus c
8 because the triangle in the plane is 6
8 10 and the hypotenuse is the sum of
the radii a plus c
we thus have the equation 8 squared plus
the quantity a minus c squared is equal
to the quantity a plus c squared
we finally make this construction one
more time on these two spheres
we'll end up with a similar equation for
these radii lengths
and the length six
so we have six squared plus the quantity
b minus c squared is equal to the
quantity b plus c squared
we now have three equations in three
variables a b and c
so we can just focus on these three
equations and focus on solving for a b
and c
let's work on the first equation
we'll expand each binomial
we can then cancel out a squared and b
squared on both sides
we can then group the 2 a b term on the
right hand side and the negative two a b
term on the left hand side
so that four a b is equal to one hundred
this means a b is equal to twenty five
in this next equation we'll expand the
binomials cancel out the a squared and c
squared terms and then group the two ac
terms so we get 4ac is equal to 8
squared which is equal to 64.
this means ac is equal to 16.
in the third equation we do a similar
calculation so we get 4bc is equal to 6
squared which equals 36. this means bc
is equal to 9.
let's now focus on these three equations
a b is equal to 25 ac is equal to 16 and
bc is equal to 9.
from the first two equations
we multiply them together to get a
squared bc
is equal to 25 times 16 which is equal
to 400
but from the third equation we know bc
is equal to 9.
this means 9a squared is equal to 400
which means a is equal to 20 over 3. we
want to take the positive root because
we're dealing with the radius of a
sphere
now that we solve for a we can
substitute in and we can solve for b and
c
substituting into the first equation
gives 20 over 3 multiplied by b is equal
to 25 which means b is equal to 15 over
4.
then substituting into the second
equation gives 20 over 3 multiplied by c
is equal to 16 which means c is equal to
12 over 5.
thus the spheres have radii lengths of
20 over 3 15 over 4 and 12 over 5.
and that's the answer
thanks for making us one of the best
communities on youtube see you next
episode of mind your decisions where we
solve the world's problems one video at
a time
[Music]
[Music]
you